be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so with the bloodshot movie coming
out or at least a trailer haven't been
released today I figured we would make
bloodshot explained I can't get my words
right I'm coming off of a cold right so
I've got my tissue I've got my toilet
paper which doubles as my tissue I got
my Vaseline to keep my nose dry you
can't stop greatness baby but with the
trailer dropping today a lot of people
probably gonna be having questions like
who is bloodshot like what's going on
with bloodshot and we are comments
explained and so of what use would our
channel be if we did not explain comics
so bloodshot originally made his
appearance in in Valiant Comics back in
like 1992 with eternal warrior issue
number four now
so valiant comics was the the brainchild
of a guy named Jim shooter and Jim
shooter got his claim to fame in the
1980s or so when he was the editor in
chief of Marvel Comics the guy ran a
tight ship it was like if your artwork
is late you're fired
if your writing is late you're fired if
you don't like the direction that we're
going in you're fired
the guy was probably one of the most
reviled editors in chief of all time in
the history of Marvel but as Joel at
Cape Joel always says by god the trains
ran on time so take it for what it's
worth but inevitably Jim shooter and
marvel parted ways and initially Jim
shooter wanted to buy Marvel comics but
of course he didn't really have the
capital to pull it off and so what he
ended up doing was getting capital from
a handful of different people some
German investors as well as a company
called triumph and this basically led to
him creating Valiant Comics and the idea
was to look at the landscape of comic
books over also look at what Marvel was
doing a look at what DC was doing and
then to look at what they weren't doing
and then in turn build publications
based off that and so because of that a
lot of stuff was really was was crate at
that point in time right you had the
Harbinger Foundation you basically had
what we're called science basically kids
who had psychic abilities different
things like that but the overall gist of
this was to really capitalize and to
build on the nature of anti-heroes and
the reason why was because Jim shooter
had looked around to come a book
landscape at that point in time and one
of the things he saw was that by and
large the traditional role of
superheroes which is to say like
Superman Wonder Woman was more or less
Eston stone right they were good guys
they did good guy things bad guys did
bad guy things the super heroes fought
the bad guys on the super heroes one and
that was basically it
but from 1971 going forward the entire
couple of landscape changed and that
changed with the night when Stacy died
because there had never been an instance
where a superhero had failed and lost
his love interest when he went from 1971
and comets got darker then you jump to
like 1986 1987 and 1988 going into the
years leading up to and after
the Dark Knight Returns when you get a
darker edgier grittier Batman suddenly
it was well the doors are blown off
right you can do pretty much anything
you want to you can depict superheroes
in a wide array of different ways and so
using that as kind of a platform Marvel
started introducing characters like
cable they started to expand a little
bit more on the character of Wolverine
who had predated a lot of those stories
for quite some time with the exception
of Wynn Stacy there was a huge amount of
popularity that was kind of boiling up
and getting ready to explode and so
trying to catch that before it really
sort of popped off and that ship set
sail well you ended up having was Kevin
Van Hook who introduced her really who
created bloodshot and then introduced
him into Valiant Comics under the under
the direction of Jim shooter now for the
the original origin of bloodshot and the
way he was originally depicted in the
first 52 issues as it was released by
valiant for the most part it was one of
these things where he was essentially a
blend between like the Punisher and
Wolverine but the way he was originally
depicted or at least the most faithful
origin he was a guy named Angelo he was
basically a mobster working his way up
the ranks and ultimately fell in love
with the daughter of his direct boss and
the result of this is that when the two
of them had a pretty reasonable
relationship a pretty good relationship
ultimately Angelo cheated and when he
did his boss tried to have him killed
and someone said of dying
Angelo turned coded he became state's
witness and then while he was being
transported by the FBI some of those
guys were on the payroll of his boss and
basically had him shipped off to Japan
where he became a part of project rising
spirit and a project rising spirit as it
existed in the original Valiant Comics
line because that's something to
understand here there's there's volume
entertainment as it exists now and then
there's Valiant Comics away it existed
back in the 90s project rising spirit
was different than the way it is now
right now it's a super-secret government
organization back then it was an
organization that was based out of Japan
and the idea was that it was somewhat of
a blend between the Hellfire Club from
Marvel Comics and the marvel's own
weapons Plus program but the idea behind
project rising spirit is that they were
an organization that wanted to have
influence throughout the world and
created all different kinds of weapons
in order to do it and one of those
things was something called the blood of
heroes and the blood of Heroes was
basically this net ID infused substance
that would be infused into somebody's
blood and then in turn offer them things
like like healing factors and so on and
so forth enhanced abilities different
things along those lines basically
creating the perfect super soldier and
so as a result of that the kind of blend
between the Hellfire Club and weapons
Plus manifested in project rising spirit
in so far that when the the entire
process was undertaken and Angelo was
basically infused
this experience amnesia and didn't know
who he was and so what ended up
happening his project rising spirit
basically started flooding his mind with
false memories and so what they would do
is they would give him false memories
and they would say see like your wife
died and this is the person that killed
him so you have to go kill that person
what's that mission was done blood shot
would be brought back his mind would be
wiped a new memory would be installed
and then he'd be sent out on another
mission again and so the result of that
is that over the course of the original
52 issues that you got from the
bloodshot comics it was very Killing
Joke esque insofar as the closest origin
you get to the Joker's in The Killing
Joke by Alan Moore but in that same
story the Joker's like but I don't even
know if it's really accurate like it
might be it might not be who really
knows people take it because it's the
best one we have Louie was very much
like that with bloodshot you didn't
really know if anything about anything
about his life was actually real you
were just kind of following him on the
journey to figure out who he was and
maybe it was real maybe he wasn't but
the overall gist of this is that
bloodshot was insanely successful it was
ridiculous how popular he was because he
fulfilled the notion of like what an
antihero could be and so far as he was a
guy who didn't know what his identity
was he was a guy who done some really
really really bad things and then once
he broke free of project rising spirit
and then went out to do his own thing
where rising spirit tried to create more
or more blood shots try to create
duplicates but couldn't quite perfectly
duplicate the blood of Heroes formula
this basically led to them trying to
send some half-measures after him all of
whom were defeated and then bloodshot
basically tried to piece his life
together
now the downside to this portion of our
explanation is that there really isn't a
whole lot of information about the
original blood shot at least not that
I've been able to really dig up I mean
there is information there but it's kind
of like essentially what I've told you
what's there it's kind of what I know
right I mean it's kind of what I know
what I've been able to find but the real
meat and potatoes and the reason why
don't really think that matters that
much is because the the current
depiction of bloodshot as he'll be shown
in the movie played by Vin Diesel is
based on the Raymond garrison persona
right and that kind of leads us into
like this massive reshuffling of value
about two years maybe not even two years
later like a year or a year and a half
after blood shot was originally
introduced we got the comic bust of the
mid-1990s right basically I we're not
gonna go into a huge explanation about
it but essentially it was a whole bunch
of people buying comic books believing
he'd be worth a lot of money later on
and then as a result publishers were
creating more comics because they didn't
know that people were buying like 10 15
20 copies of a single comic book and
that basically led to come
but purchasers were or the fanbase or
what have you almost destroying the
comic-book market and so as a result of
that valiant was one of the companies
that just couldn't stay afloat right
Marvel almost went bankrupt and they
were saved by Ike Perlmutter and avi
arad over a toy biz and DC had been
owned by one of others for some forever
for quite some time so they were never
gonna go broke but valiant didn't really
have anybody to keep them afloat right
so they ended up struggling and they
ended up being bought out by acclaim
entertainment who at the time as most of
you guys know was making video games the
problem with acclaim entertainment is
they pretty much had all their eggs in
one basket
their single largest source of revenue
basically came from creating WWF
wrestling games the problem with this
was that in 1999 WF bailed out they
basically took off because I believe
that at the time THQ was creating
wrestling video games for WCW and of
course those are the guys who familiar
with wrestling the Monday Night Wars
were alive and well albeit getting ready
to sound their death knell and about two
years right she doesn't have one it's
really when it all went belly-up but
1999 I think was really when it was at
about its peak but the result was that
with THQ creating games that were far
more well received than what acclaim was
doing wbf left they took a lion's share
of a claims profit with them and a claim
was no longer financially solvent so in
around 2004 they found for chapter 7
bankruptcy they went belly-up and where
claim had released stories about valiant
characters continuing the Valiant Comics
line and then creating video games off
those characters the result was that
valiance popularity at the time wasn't
as high as it was back in the early
1990s because they were the new kid on
the block right and people largely
bought into valiant because the
collector market as opposed to you know
having like a super hardcore fan base so
as a result of that when the claim was
making games because of the fact that
the claim also just wasn't really making
great comics about died in either
ultimately it all just went just went
belly-up and all this kind of kind of
tanked and so following that that's when
you got into around 2005 or so with
Dinesh Sharma Sahni and Jacek Authority
and these two guys basically showed up
and and I mean these guys exploded onto
the scene right they were just like by
everything that's related to value
that's originally owned by them and the
reason why was because Dyan at the time
was creating stories on various
characters that were out there that
weren't really owned by them whom they
were licensing from different companies
but of course once everything kind of
went belly-up with acclaim those rights
reverted back to the original companies
and then Dinesh Shan Bassani and JC
Kothari bought all the original
creations by valued so exilim an award
Lutz shot different things like that
Harbinger and and so on so
and so as a result of that going into
2012 that's when you saw this summer of
value this explosion of valued comics
and it was really cool because it
coincided with DC's new 52 launch and it
was one of those things were like it
just kind of blew up right it was just
kind of like BAM everybody was talking
about it because it was almost like 1990
you know that's 92 93 all over again not
tiny one because you had DC and you had
Marvel right DC was doing a reboot with
the new 52 Marvel was trying to try to
capitalize or trying to shouldn't say
hey you should come read us too and so
they did Marvel now and then value just
kind of blew up out there and said hey
guys let's all go read value comics and
so what they ended up doing was they
actually ended up browning a little bit
of the history of bloodshot they brought
Jeff Lemire on which is one of the best
things they could do because Jeff Lemire
had made a huge name for himself and
Marvel and DC at that point so they
brought Jeff Lemire on had him read
bloodshot and then borrowed from both
what acclaim had done and then what
dying comics had done insofar as angelo
march foley was one of the aliases of
let's shot but for the most part the
true identity that we could get or at
least the closest we could get was
raymond garrison now the big difference
is that that kind of came out of this
the way things began to change is that
what you had here is instead of him
having been a mobster that was roped
into you know the project rising spirit
which is a Japanese based company
instead project rising spirit was
brought closer in line with the weapons
Plus program for Marvel insofar as like
the original Super Soldier right like
trying to create the perfect super
soldier and so as a result of that but
with Raymond garrison going forward and
essentially being this guy who as best
as he could recall was a soldier who was
essentially roped into project rising
spirits the big thing that came out of
this was this idea that one of the
biggest struggles project rising spirit
had was trying to find a way to create
super soldiers who would carry out
missions without question and there
would be no morality cause that come in
right like their moral compass wouldn't
get in the way they would be cold
blooded they would be you know clean-cut
and thorough and that's it they would go
in there would complete the mission and
they would be done creating robots more
or less and so as a result of that with
with bloodshot being like their prized
pupil he ultimately actually ended up
turning on project rising spirit another
way that Sean Dasani and Jeff Lemire and
all these guys did it was actually
pretty genius so instead of just having
this scenario where one day he just kind
of pieces his memories together and it
just sort of goes forward which is
something you could get away with back
in the 90s and if you weren't really
gonna question it that gag had already
been done and so what they did is they
shifted things up and so the way this
worked was that after blood shot had
been taken in by project rising spirit
or at least after raymond had been taken
in by project
spirit and made him to the character
that he was made into this kind of you
know merciless killing machine super
soldier which Tom Dasani in them did is
they said okay let's take these
different things that we're doing over
here right so we have Harbinger which is
basically all the science all the kids
with like mental abilities we have these
things over here let's bring them all
closer in line right so it was like from
the word go
it was just like this this crossover
sort of thing and so what they ended up
doing was aimed up saying okay so we're
gonna have project rising spirit look at
the the looming threat of tell Hirata
and his sion army which he's basically a
masih which had his own problems in the
form of peter stan check like inciting
incident still you Hirata which is
really really cool but seeing that is a
looming threat that could potentially
challenge the role that project rising
spirit plays they basically tasks
bloodshot with going and taking out
various Saiyans and so while that was
going on because of the fact that
project rising spirit was stretched so
thin there was a scientist by the name
of courage i think i'm not sure exactly
how to pronounce his name but basically
we're gonna come cures i think that's
how you how cure it ashore curettage or
simple on those lines but he was
basically a guy working with a project
and it essentially turned against it and
so he bailed out he ended up joining toi
johannes harbinger foundation and then
while bloodshot was on a mission in
afghanistan he was taken by curettage
and then his nanites were essentially
modified a reprogrammed to reveal two
bloodshot that nothing about his life
that he believed was real was actually
real that none of it was true as the
following that bloodshot ended up
hurting our project rising spirit
working alongside harbinger that of
course is history kind of follows suit
to the modern day but nonetheless I mean
bloodshot as a curator or like if you
look at his original creation he was a
blend between Wolverine of the Punisher
what if you had a guy who basically was
brought together as kind of like these
two characters the terms of a guy who
was an antihero who was like a merciless
killing machine but then also had like a
healing factor of wolf rain what if you
had that kind of military s kaback story
possibly maybe depending on whether the
memories are real or not and then set
him forward to do that bidding he was
one of the best anti heroes to come out
of comics in the early 1990s but of
course again dyin ended up going
belly-up and that led to them being
bought by claim which went belly-up and
then bought by you know Dinesh Sharma
Dasani and JC Kothari being relaunched
with with dyin entertainment but
bloodshot has a huge fan following and
this is really kind of the question that
I'm curious about when it comes to the
film because you're talking about a guy
who by virtue of that man dies that he
receives it has like all these
enhancements right enhance speed and
agility reflexes different things like
that he's got an advanced healing factor
that allows him to withstand huge
amounts of damage and then like
think about as life seems to be real and
that's that's gonna be kind of the cool
thing going in is because what I'm
curious about is the various cutscenes
that we have with Vin Diesel talking to
his wife saying like oh I'm gonna go
after the guys who kill my wife is that
just one of the many personalities of
the many memories that bloodshot's
received and if that's the case that I'm
curious what direction that's gonna go
in because that's a lot to cram into a
single movie it would be like if you sat
down and you watch The Joker film and
like you basically got like six origins
of the Joker over the course of the film
and then it culminates in none of its
real everything that he believes it's
not true and then you get the climax
right so like this setup is he has all
these different lives that he lives
right like all he's in memories that he
has and the conflict is none of those
lives are real and the conclusion is
he's taking out the people that gave him
those false memories it's a lot of stuff
to introduce into a film it's a lot of
stuff to throw in there but given the
fact that the movie looks pretty solid
just in the trailers and it's got Vin
Diesel it's got Guy Pearce who I've been
a fan of since he won an Oscar I think
it's gonna be a solid movie I think it's
gonna be a pretty fantastic film I
really do think and this is where I
think the movies really gonna shine is I
think that what valiance doing here with
regards to the bloodshot film is one of
the best things they could do because
say for example that they went with
somebody like faith so the character of
faith I loved her the way she was to
pick it she was bubbly she was happy she
was cheery
but that's been done before right that's
the Marvel Cinematic Universe guy and
when I think the what I think diet is
doing is looking to the success of
divinity you know whether you what do
you dig it's a great film or not you
can't deny it was a success of the
box-office right it did exceedingly well
I loved the movie you look at the
success of the Joker and what you see is
this rising trend where villains and
anti-heroes are starting to take stage
over like traditional superheroes and I
said that back when the venom movie was
being released right when I have that
interview and everything I said hey guys
this movie is gonna be amazing
this is gonna change the standard of
companies going forward there would be
the bane of the existence of the MCU
because what the MCU has constantly been
killing off their villains Sony and NBC
or looking at that and saying yeah but
like sometimes the villains are more
interesting than the heroes so let's
make movies about them and it's proven
to be hugely successful bloodshot in the
beginning when you when you see them to
pigeon as a character you're gonna see
like just merciless killing right just
like just bloodlust you're just gonna
see like a blood lusted Punisher or
Wolverine s character just killing
everything right just killing everything
but as the character develops and
the character grows you're gonna see
some huge changes and you're gonna see
some really really really cool evolution
there I'm excited to see was to see how
the movie turns out it's gonna be
something spectacular I will say that I
think the movies gonna be pretty darn
solid because I think it's gonna be kind
of another notch in the belt of moving
movie movies towards the direction of
focusing on anti heroes and villains as
opposed to focusing on straight-up
heroes but would that be said guys we're
gonna read this video to an end if you
are new here to come as explained unless
you guys are the sub button to become
part of the rob4 if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]